what's going on guys national master
james kante the third here with
chess.com and today we have the top
five world championship blunders yes
even the best
of the best blunder as well in this
first example we have anatoly karpov
versus gary
kasparov in the 1987 world championship
match
let's see what's going on here so it's
white to move here and of course uh
black's
black is attacking the rook here gary
kasparov is attacking this rook
it's a lot of things going on looks like
king safety is kind of wild for a little
bit both but definitely white
so anatoly carpenter says queen takes a6
here actually
now we're eyeing g6 maybe we have this
check here as well
and we're also defending g4 at the same
time here now gary these guys are both
in time trouble right now actually
there's a video actually
you can find online there is a video now
oh of this exact position but what
happened here is gary looked around the
board
and he's like i need to figure this out
g4 would be made queen takes g4 is
definitely
checkmate if i can divert this rook in
somehow some way so what does he do he
diverts the rook by playing
rook a1 but at the same time it's an
absolute
blunder the game is over after the next
move here
and of course anatoly karpov if you
watch the video he just
calmly wrote down the move and then he
looked up and he made his move no
emotion at all
just made the move here queen takes g6
and gary was like oh my goodness what
did i do
i cannot believe i just gave this game
away
immediately a blunder and he resigned
right after this move
the reason being guys is queen g6 not
only is a check but it defends the czech
mate
that was here on g4 and the intention
after rook a1 was if rookie won with an
obvious reasons guys if rook takes
there's pawn takes which is a beautiful
pretty mate here and also queen takes
with her both
checkmate here guys they're both
checkmate but actually he chose rookie
run here because he was in
time trouble time trouble gets the best
of us he chose rick a1 and queen takes
g6
bam there it is now we're checking the
king also defending no matter what you
do here we're just gonna take on a1 and
the game
is virtually over here guys and that was
blunder number one
of the world championships now let's get
on to blunder number two okay guys now
on to blunder number two we have victor
korchnoy versus anatoly karpov in 1978
guys
let's actually see what happened here
karpov plays rook to c6 kind of a wild
position here actually i mean when is
the last time you've ever seen a
position like this
or any time you've seen a position with
two knights in the rook versus two rooks
and some pawns
very dynamic position king placements
kind of weird here maybe some mating
threats especially especially after rook
to c6
threatening rook c1 checkmate on the
move very very wild position here white
needs to do something he needs to defend
the check menu on a back rank
and you have a few ways to do so rather
pushing the h pawn with some left for
the king
pushing the g pawn with the same idea or
moving the rook back to defend
the rank here what would you do actually
with the white pieces here to defend
this checkmate if i gave you five
seconds what would you choose in this
position if you
were victor courchnoy
here we go guys all right now let me
tell you what the answer is
the answer is actually g3 or g4
surprising right it seems like you would
push the h pawn but you actually get
mated by pushing the h-bond so g3 or g4
is actually the only move in this
position
and victor courchnoy chose rook to a1
and that my friend
is not a move it is a complete blunder
right here
can you find the move the sequence that
uh our anatoly karpov played in his
position to win
the game guys black to move what would
you do
here we go guys look at this next move
oh my goodness knight
f3 check whoa knight f3 check i can just
take the knight can't i
i can just take the knight well what
about king h1 what if i just move my
king over well then hey
just have a nice day smothered mate this
is beautiful this is going into books
for everyone to see for history
right so this is just not fun to play
that at all victor cautionoid
knew that this hurt here and he had to
take the knight he was actually he was
forced to resign in this position
but this is was actually what it was if
if we do see
pawn takes knight um on f3 here well
what's the next move class here we are
here it is
always check it might be made check
there it is the king has to go
somewhere you only have one move to go
to and after king h1
oh my goodness mate with the knights so
beautiful the pieces were so beautifully
placed here
rk1 was such a blunder but it's not an
easy blunder it wasn't just like a
huge blunder it was just hard to see was
one of the blunders that like
i didn't know it was a blunder rook a1
looks perfectly fine
until you play anatoly karpov who says
think again
think again okay think again here that
was blunder number two guys that really
hurts here and the only way to get out
of this was actually g3
or g4 so if there are any checks you
kind of just have to run the king away
and somehow some way
maybe even giving up one of the rigs for
the night and hoping for a draw
fighting for a draw here because the
pieces are placed very nicely here
what an amazing checkmate by anatoly
karpov here
back in 1978 in this world championship
match guys that was blunder
number two and now let's move on to
blender number three
now we move on to blunder number three
world championship blunder number three
in this game we have david bronstein
versus mikhail
botvinik in 1951
guys all right so let's check this out
now it's actually black to move here
right now
mikhail bapunic says i'm going to queen
my pawn i'm going to queen
there is an extra knight here and right
here you have to stop this pawn from
queening right or you're just going to
lose the game david bronstein
understands that here so he's trying to
figure out the best way to do this now
what would you play in david bronstein's
shoes here how do you actually stop this
pawn is there a way to stop this pawn
what would you do
well here we go guys the best move and
best sequence is actually knight to e6
followed by knight to d4 and we just
stopped upon
pretty simple and actually ends up being
some type of draw here but white wants
more lights up a piece and he wants to
win this game so what he chooses is
actually king to c2
which is actually a full on
game over blunder now what bronstein
expected right here actually
was what guys let's actually see if you
can figure that out black to move
mikhail bob and nick you're playing bob
venice shoes here what do you think you
should do
what do you think you should do what
would be your your your number one move
what would that be
here it is guys actually david bronstein
and many other players here were
actually expecting king to f3
and if king to f3 then knight comes in
and if king f2 are pushing the pawn
doesn't matter how you do it we're
putting knight to d4
and we're just going to take the pawn
here pretty simple here right but
mikhail baphanix says haha
i don't have to go king f3 i don't have
to go king f3
at all he actually plays this right here
king to g3
shocked david brunstein didn't even
believe he was like is that it even a
real move is it even legal
it's there the game ends on the spot
right here guys the game was over as we
finish it out here
king to g3 now after king g3 if you try
the same move
knight here you push it now we're going
to queen
how do you stop the queen you got to go
here and then we zigzag
right into checkmate here right into
queening followed by checkmate coming
right after very soon right it hurts to
see it as soon as he saw king to g3 shot
oh my goodness
i can't believe this even happened what
just happened here i'm up a full piece
now i'm losing
the game because there's nothing else to
do the only move in this position was
moving the knight to e6 and coming
around and ended up taking the pawn
and settling for a draw absolutely
insane
how this happened here it was a huge
blunder king c2 was just a blunder on
the spot
king g3 wins on the spot nothing you can
do even bringing the king to either
square we go king f2 and we queen india
anyway
what a blunder back in 1951 world
championship david bronstein versus
mikhail boppinic and that was blunder
number three guys
so now let's move on to world
championship blunder number four
all right guys now does this blunder
look familiar to anyone
does anyone remember this position this
was
magnus carlson versus vishwanathan anad
back in 2014. okay guys this is world
championship match
and actually right here it's white to
move fish one of the neonatal not just
went this she just went rook to ga here
rook d to ga
and actually just putting some pressure
on the g file here now
magnus for thinking for a little bit
actually plays
this move here king to d2 straight up
blunder blunder guys king to d2
is not a move here now what black is
supposed to do what do you mean supposed
to do
didn't he make the move in the game no
he didn't he missed it does she
not miss the winning move here he
actually plays a4
in the game in the game the game he
returned the favor here
actually and plays a4 but was what was
supposed to happen that could have ended
the game
very quickly guys in a few moves here
can you spot the move that vicious
and magnus carlsen both of them missed
the surprising
tactic here that basically wins the game
you can go on to win the game from this
position
what do you actually play here with
black
this is what vichy missed he missed
knight takes e5 guys
right here knight takes e5 bam what a
shot
oh my goodness knight takes e5 it's a
simple blow but it ends the game on the
spot well what's going on
why is 965 any winning isn't the knight
hanging absolutely it's hanging but your
rook's hanging you take my knight
i take your rook that's an easy win or
how about you know maybe uh rook takes
rook first which is probably going to be
the best line
rook takes rook then after uh knight
takes c4
in in between move when inter meso or
what they call a jitsu
at the same time knight takes c4 is
checked so you have two moves king e2 or
king and d3
he too doesn't do anything i'm just
going to play take back on g8
now if king to d3 knight to b2 check
another
in between move before coming and taking
the rook here king moves
no matter where you go i'm going to take
on g8 and we're going to go on to win
this game with this hanging of course
we're up a little bit of material now of
course bishops versus knight here but
this is not what
magnus wanted at all here now they both
missed it guys they absolutely both both
missed it here
which is absolutely amazing and a4
a4 was actually the move played in the
game here guys but what a blunder
missed by the way by both of the world
champions
100 percent uh amazing here that even
the best of the best
miss these type of shots all the time a4
was played knight takes e5 was winning
guys
i remember actually watching this and i
was like knight takes e5 i remember
feeling it like that looks good
and he missed it and everyone around the
world went crazy
that he missed vicious miss knight takes
e5 guys this was blunder number four
and now we're going to move on to the
final world championship blunder
of today and here we are guys with
blunder
number five world championship blunder
number five does anyone
recognize this position very famous very
very famous position here
if i give you five seconds can you call
this game
who is playing this game what world
championship match is this one
here we go guys it is boris spassky
versus robert james fisher aka bobby
fischer
back in 1972 here let's actually see
what happened
now white plays b5 and actually just
virtually an equal game this should end
up being a draw
pawns on both sides of the board same
color bishop here
king's a slightly better place for white
but honestly objectively just a drawn
position with perfect play
now what happened here is bobby fischer
just played
the absolute the craziest move you can
see here we didn't understand it why was
it played
but it was played it was a blunder 100
a blunder here guys here it is bishop
takes h2 he just takes the pawn
takes the pawn bishop takes h2 is not a
move
in any way shape and form and after
bishop takes h2
boris baskey just looks at him and looks
down at the board
and looks back up at him and then plays
g3 your bishop is trapped and then we're
going to walk our king over
and take it now after h5 king 2 h4 king
f3 king e7 king g2
and the game's over take pawn take pawn
oh thank you thank you very much
that's the piece and boris baskey went
on to win this game
amazing how we just blunder sometimes
even the best of the best
make blunders now not all the time they
blunder way less than we do they're half
human
and have something else from a different
chess planet but at the same time they
still make blunders here what a blunder
by bobby fisher here bishop takes h2
g3 and the game was virtually over guys
this is a famous blunder here guys
definitely do your research on this one
check out our chess.com articles on this
one as well
and others world championship blunders
as well thank you so much for watching
today's video guys i'm national master
james canty iii with chess.com guys and
i'll see you
on the next video